game two of this best of three the white
sox have a chance to win in advance the
a's need a win to keep their season
alive chris bassett 11 starts in the
regular season you mentioned how good he
was in september he was the pitcher of
the month
in the american league
how about the big curve ball for strike
three swinging first strikeout of the
day for chris bassett well dallas kykel
who's got tons of playoff experience had
a really good first year with the white
sox so oakland building a rally here in
the middle of their lineup against
dallas keiko who was
unscored upon in the first inning this
year
that one was 103 miles an hour off the
bat that one hit a little softer toward
the middle anderson spins and his throw
is wide
its bases loaded with two down
olson hits a hard ground ball and it
kicks up and away from madrigal into
right field la stella is in
and right behind him loriano he scores
two nothing a's it was clear olsen was
looking inner half and he gets enough of
this one yeah it's on the ground but he
hits it hard magigle up the brim of his
glove
chris bassett who gave up one run in
september
2-2
he threw one inside and got him to swing
and missed 95 miles an hour
had to come back to the plate simeon
drills one to center robert back look it
up it is gone
marcus simeon to straight away center
field
and the a's double their lead it's four
nothing they are hitting the ball hard
one guy after another against kykel
kykel on that one it was supposed to be
a two seamer a sinker that was supposed
to continue down instead it stays
simeon all over it ramon loriano
that's a swing says ted barrett so
strike three loriano is retired
first and second nobody out it's now mon
kata white sox have a chance to get
right back in this game and he drills
one to left center field at the wall
leaping catch by canna what a play
and this time madrigal does have to go
back pinder all the way to first not in
time anderson
was sure that ball wasn't going to be
caught what a play by mark canna
now keiko for the bottom of the third
showed off his defensive skills he
swings and missed the misses there
grandahl will complete the put out with
the throw
that one is strike three called kaiko
got the call
out number two the third straight
strikeout for dallas kykel
chris davis chance to play today the d.h
he drives that one to left field he
thinks he got it did he get it yes he
did chris davis gone five nothing a's
that's the chris davis swing we saw for
those big power years chris davis so
simple with his swing he just kind of
opens that front toe the knee gets his
barrel there and gone you're right flem
as soon as he hit this he knew it well
chris bassett in the uh
as he's pitching the lucasg inning
struck him out swinging so two down a's
trying to keep their season going and in
great position to do so behind chris
bassett
now collins late on a 95 mile an hour
fastball strike three that's a big out
number two mick madrigal will hit with
two on it two out
pitch number 91 madrigal beats it into
the dirt and wasn't real happy about it
hayes make the play bassett gets through
seven shutout innings of the order up
for the white sox in inning number eight
five-nothing a's trying to extend their
season by at least one more day and what
else is new tim anderson's got another
hit well bob melvin's coming out so
whether he conveyed that to bassett or
not and as soon as he allowed a base
runner he was coming out of the game i
mean this is interesting i think liam
hendricks is the guy
that one is swung on and foul tipped at
96 miles an hour strike three grundahl
against hendricks
grandahl to right field
well hit biscotti back looking up and it
is gone
for the second straight game yes monty
grandall has gone deep
and the lead for the a's is down to
three
to bob melvin being super aggressive
with his
all-star closer liam hendricks and
hendricks gives up the two-run homer
three and two huge pitch to make mazzara
wow the call went hendricks weighed that
strike three he was convinced it was
ball four the pitch
robert strikes out swinging 97 miles an
hour henries keeps the damage down the
a's three outs away from forcing a
winner take all game three
strike three swinging 96 miles an hour
angle goes down
two and two to dyson
strike three called the white sox
are not going quietly
tying run will come to home plate
another 3-2 pitch to moncada
it is off the inside ball four bob
melvin's coming out the bases are loaded
hendricks could not get the final out
and jake diekmann's gonna have to be the
guy to save the day for the a's my
goodness
great hitters count for grundahl 3-1 is
outside ball four dickman has walked in
a run and jose abreu
will come up with the bases still loaded
the lead down to two
incredible
5-3
a's still looking desperately for that
final out that one is smoked on one hop
to second
orf has it and he throws out abreu
somehow the a's survive
unbelievable drama in the last couple
innings